it is now two days after election day
people have been voting in some States
since September and we are still waiting
to find out for sure who won control of
the house and of the Senate if you were
born before 2017 or so you will remember
a time when America was able to conduct
elections in one day
you know like France or Brazil
or every other even quasi-democracy on
planet Earth apparently though that is
over now so we're all just waiting and
we're waiting on three Senate races in
particular
Republicans currently have won or held
49 seats Democrats 48 seats
in Nevada the Republican Adam laxalt is
leading by 20 000 votes that's 49.6
percent to 47.4 percent and that is with
79 percent of the vote in as of last
night in Georgia the race between
Herschel Walker and Rafael Warnock is
essentially tied and headed for a runoff
and in Arizona Democrat Mark Kelly is
leading Republican Blake masters with 70
of the vote in with no sign of when the
race will be settled for sure and on top
of that Arizona's gubernatorial race
looks like it could be headed to court
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
back to the show my favorite comment
yesterday is from cool Papa J magic that
guy gets so many of my and I don't even
see their names when I pick the comment
that's very impressive cool Papa J magic
he says Carrie like they gotta fix this
problem Democrats you're having issues
because the problem has already been
fixed so true so true I think people are
looking at this thing a little bit
backwards sometimes we we know that
paper ballots work so why are we moving
to these computers and these machines
that sometimes don't work and drag the
vote count out for many days and weeks
when there can be more fraud and okay I
think I understand it now I think I get
it we need to be revved up okay we need
to be fired up we need to be peppy we
need to be alert about our elections
throughout our entire life and when you
want to be peppy and alert you got to
check out Black Rifle coffee right now
head on over to blackriflecoffee.com
enter promo code Knowles while today's
coffee often comes with hints of soy and
just little notes of social justice
Black Rifle de delivers an entirely
different experience bold strong and
delicious Black Rifle coffee is the
coffee that I choose to get me through
the day Black Rifle coffee company is
veteran founded and operated their
mission is to help service members
successfully transition from the
military into entrepreneurship they
provide assistance to Veterans who seek
to launch businesses of their own with
the goal of helping more companies such
as Black Rifle become a reality Black
Rifle is committed to hiring ten
thousand veterans they're well on their
way as for the coffee itself because
frankly for me
even beyond all the great work Black
Rifle does the coffee that's what I'm
interested in Black Rifle is very
selective about where they Source their
coffee beans very disciplined when it
comes to ensuring the freshness of every
bag go to Black riflecoffee.com use
promo code Knolls for 10 off your first
order or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription the
subscription gives you free shipping on
all coffee Club orders Early Access to
Club deals and promotions and special
discounts from their partner Brands
that's black riflecoffee.com promo code
knows for 10 off your first order or
when you sign up to become a coffee Club
member Black Rifle coffee supporting
veterans and America's coffee
do you think we're going to get the
Arizona election results before or after
the next midterm elections
I assume I'd like to think we'll get it
before 2026 but I don't know it's kind
of weird
don't you think we should be able to
count the votes
and give Carrie like her job
but it's relatively soon no maybe not
not in America anymore we're not an
advanced country like Brazil
you know we're only the United States of
America why could we conduct elections
some of the races do seem truly to be
tight even as they're properly counting
all the votes there's one house race
should be my friend Lauren bobert Lauren
bobert in Colorado running against Adam
Frisch
the race right now is
so Frisch has a technically by 50
50.01 percent to Lauren bobert's 49.99
percent
the vote count is fresh
155
579 to bobert 155 5506.
and by the way actually those are the
numbers as of last night I think it's
actually tightened up since then so it
was it was separated by what 73 votes
now I think it's actually 60 something
votes so it's just
shockingly
implausibly close
it reminds us that every vote matters I
mean there have been elections that are
decided by 200 votes and I think that
it's easy for Republicans to be
depressed and say all the Democrats
rigged they changed all the voting rules
and they're going to drag out the
counter in some cases they they don't
want poll Watchers to pay attention to
what's going on and coincidentally the
voting machines and the conservative
precincts break and it's just easy to
get depressed
but that's what they're counting on they
are discouraging Republicans they don't
want us to show up to vote but if 65
Vote or whatever 75 voters in Laurens
District who were Republicans had showed
up to vote who didn't
that could have been the difference in
the election we'll see I mean that
there will have to be a recount if we're
only talking about 70 or some odd votes
uh now regardless of what happens in
that race I obviously hope Lauren pulls
it out Joe Biden is signaling now that
he thinks that the GOP is going to take
the house and he is intimated that he's
willing to work with the House GOP and
he's the Biden world seems to have
accepted that reality but a lot of
people are asking this question where
was the Red Wave
where was the red wave that we were all
promised that we saw reflected in all of
these polls where is it
and it's difficult to work through
because the polls are often wrong but
they're almost always wrong in in the
democrats favor so they all almost
always over sample Democrats and they
say things are going to go a lot better
for the Democrats and then the
Republicans outperform the polls and
that's when we always say well don't
believe the polls but it's always in
that direction so what do we make of
this here were the polls so many of the
polls
seem to favor the Republicans and the
Republicans underperformed
I think it is important to remember
that as you hear people bickering over
why the Republicans had such a poor
showing and how it's Trump's fault and
no it's the voter Integrity issue fault
and no it's the this fault no it's that
fault
don't forget this talk of the red
tsunami only really began in the last
few weeks if you were talking about the
polls in September
then it was much less clear and if you
were talking about the polls six months
ago is much less clear
six months ago and even back in
September the talk was yeah Republicans
will probably take the house but it's
kind of 50 50 on the Senate because it's
a tough election map this year for the
Republicans
it was only in the last couple of weeks
that the pollsters started talking about
no Republicans are going to take 54
seats 50 for the 56 seats maybe but that
was not the talk for the vast majority
of this campaign so I'm not I'm not
trying to help Republicans cope with a
disappointing night but it is important
to have some of that perspective if the
Republicans can take the house and
especially if the Republicans can take
the Senate that is a win that is a big
win you only need 51 or 52 Senators
there to stop the Biden agenda
and even just taking the house can
heavily impede the Biden agenda though
not nearly as much as if we take the
Senate and then it's got to rile us up
for next time I think a lot of the
battle over over what happened on the
midterm election night and even some of
the catastrophizing of that is frankly a
facade for people who are already
campaigning for candidates in 2024.
and it is a it is a warning though for
Republicans next time
maybe we need to be wary of the polls
too just as Democrats need to be wary of
the polls maybe we need to recognize
sometimes the polls will overestimate
Republicans chances so now the Senate
might all come down to Georgia depends
what happens with Arizona Masters and
Cali and then what happens
in Nevada with the lack salt raise
but let's say they split it
that Republicans win one of the
Democrats win one which right now seems
to be where the numbers are so then you
could be looking once again just like in
2020 Georgia decides to control of the
Senate
now this is probably not great news to
Republicans who remember that last time
we had a Georgia runoff with Leffler and
Purdue on the ticket we lost and then we
lost control of the Senate
I think this is different
uh so just the facts here
the runoff is going to take place
December 6th early voting must begin by
November 28th in All Counties uh but it
could begin even a couple days earlier
November 26th or November 27th
are Republicans going to stay home like
they did in 2020 or are they going to
get out and vote I think probably
Republicans will get out and vote in
this one
and I think the reason for that is that
other than whatever the hell is going on
in Arizona the problem of voter fraud
doesn't seem to be quite as widespread
as it was in 2020. I know we're not
allowed to say that there's any voter
fraud or any Shenanigans or any rigging
but there obviously was a ton of rigging
going on in 2020 and the Democrats
admitted that in that longtime magazine
article and they changed all the rules
Before the Race So I think
it was perfectly
reasonable for republicans in Georgia in
2020 to feel dispirited and say screw it
I'm not going to go vote because the
Democrats are just stealing this thing
and I know maybe I'm in the minority of
conservative pundits who is willing to
say that but I think it's perfectly
understandable why Georgia voters in
2020 who saw all of these Shenanigans
who saw a complete upending of election
laws over nonsense over a Chinese cough
would say you know what I'm I'm not
going to go vote but 2022 is different
and this year you saw major Republican
gains and you saw the vast majority of
election results come in on Election
night which greatly I think reduces
people's skepticism of the election and
so and now you have a real race here
okay and Raphael Warnock is really
really bad and Herschel Walker will be a
reliable Republican conservative vote
and they threw some bad Oppo at Herschel
in October the October surprises were
tough and they said he had all sorts of
women problems and they said that he
they even accused him of paying for an
abortion again I'm not totally sure that
that happened but even if it did you
know you've got a choice here between
Raphael Warnock who wants abortion on
demand up until the 17th trimester you
know and and and is going to be a rubber
stamp vote for the Democrats who want to
subsidize that with your taxpayer
dollars or you got Herschel Walker who's
going to be a reliably pro-life vote
who are you going to pick obviously it
ought to be Herschel so we'll see the
problem in Georgia is that Brian Kemp
vastly outperformed Herschel Walker and
Kemp won't be on the ballot this time to
help bring Walker up but nevertheless I
mean if this is if this actually does
become the race that determines control
of the Senate I think there is going to
be a fair amount of voter enthusiasm and
I think that Republican suppression that
comes from the dispiritedness of 2020. I
don't think that you were going to see
that quite as much this time so that the
race once again for control of the
Senate is going to go on for another
month or so but Republicans I think do
have a real shot at it now once that's
settled 2024 we are off to the races and
Donald Trump is not holding back his
fire
now when you want to express your
political views in this oppressive kind
of culture you're probably going to want
to anonymize yourself that's why you got
to check out expressvpn right now head
on over to expressvpn.com Knowles do you
know what big Tech and our corrupt big
government have in common they both want
to silence any dissenting voices into
submission let's say that you're a gun
owner you want to talk on social media
about your right to keep and bear arms
your Second Amendment right well that
post will probably be flagged by a
Content moderator and you will end up on
a government watch list to fight back
against having your voice censored by
both big Tech and our corrupt big
government I recommend expressvpn big
Tech tracks everything you do online
they match your activity to your
identity using your device's unique IP
address when I use expressvpn big Tech
cannot see my IP address making me
virtually anonymous
plus expressvpn encrypts 100 of my
internet data to protect me from hackers
and eavesdroppers expressvpn is by far
the greatest VPN I've ever tried you
don't need to take my word for it it's a
number one rated VPN by CNET Business
Insider and countless other Tech
Publications stop letting big Tech and
our corrupt big government sensor and
track you protect yourself at
expressvpn.com Knowles
expresvpn.com Knowles to get three
months free that is expressvpn.com
Knowles the midterms are over we're
going to be counting the votes until
we're all along in the tooth but the
midterms are over
so Donald Trump seems to be running
full steam ahead 2024 and he is going
after his chief rival Ron DeSantis
real hard uh president Trump just gave
an interview on news Nation where he
explained why he is so offended that Ron
DeSantis appears to be running
for president
abroad is a person I've always had a
decent relationship with him but when I
endorsed him he was he was gone he was
not going to be able to even be a factor
in the race and as soon as I endorsed
him within moments he the race was over
I got him the nomination he didn't get
it I got it because the minute I made
that endorsement he got it then he ran
and he wasn't supposed to be able to win
I did two rallies we had
52 000 people each one and
we ended up he won and I thought that he
could have been more gracious but that's
up to him I like that at the end he says
I'm entirely responsible for Rhonda
Sanders's political career okay the
guy's nothing without me and so listen
I thought he should be a little bit
gracious okay but hey look all right I'm
not saying anything here and and this
answer from Trump is a very good answer
to the chief anti-trump attack right now
which is that India's midterm elections
the Trump
picks in the primaries were total losers
Trump has terrible picks in the
primaries and and Trump's answer to that
is hey guys
DeSantis was one of my primary picks so
the argument is Trump's picks in the
primaries are terrible and maybe Ron
desantises would be better he says oh
yeah hey get guess who guess who one of
my most prominent primary picks was Ron
DeSantis thank you very much so that
that's his argument here uh then he's
taking to truth social he's not taking
to Twitter he's not on Twitter anymore
but he's taking to truth social and he
says now that the election of Florida is
over and everything went quite well
shouldn't it be said that in 2020 I got
1.1 million more votes in Florida than
Ron D got this year 5.7 million to 4.6
million he goes just asking
it's like you know it's not really
comparable because presidential election
years more people show up to vote than
in the midterm elections but
look I don't think it's a great look for
Trump I think it makes it look like he
is insecure about his ability to win the
nomination Ron DeSantis did not attack
him first and is not attacking him back
if DeSantis were attacking Trump then I
think it would be probably all right for
him but the fact that DeSantis is not
attacking him it doesn't look great for
Donald Trump but I tell you
as always
the the reaction to Trump's statements
and tweets or fake tweets here now the
truth social tweets
I think a lot of it depends on the tone
in which you you hear him
so for instance some of the big
headlines are if you read that truth
social
tweet as I did much better than Ron
DeSantis I got I got 1.1 million he got
four 1.1 million more votes he got he
only got 4.6 million I got 5.7 million
right if you just read it like that then
it seems kind of petulant and annoying
and but if you read it as hey how come
nobody's talking about this you know I
did a lot better I'm just asking you
know if you read it as a joke it's it's
much funnier obviously and it it reads
much differently I'll give you a better
example of this there was a big headline
where it said Donald Trump says
if candidates win on the midterm in the
midterms then he deserves all the credit
but if the candidates lose he deserves
none of the blame can you believe this
do you believe this Donald Trump you
know and so I I read that headline and I
said what did he actually say I went to
the clip here's here's what he said
you've endorsed more than 330 candidates
this election cycle tonight win or lose
the results for Republicans
um how much of that will be because of
Donald Trump
well I think if they win I should get
all the credit and if they lose I should
not be blamed at all okay but it'll
probably be just the opposite uh when
they win I think they're going to do
very well I'll probably be given very
little credit even though in many cases
I told people to run and they ran and
they turned out to be very good
candidates you know they've turned out
to be very good candidates but usually
what would happen is when they do well I
won't be given any credit and if they do
badly they will blame everything in me
so I'm prepared for anything but we'll
defend ourselves so it's the same words
that you're reading in the headline but
it's a completely different tone and if
you're watching it on TV you can see
that as Trump's saying that he's got a
little smirk
says oh what's my take on the midterms
here's what I think should happen if
they win I should get all the credit and
if they lose I shouldn't get any of the
blame you know it's going to be the
opposite but I listen my preference
would be that and he's joking he's
joking it's a joke okay and I remember
this in 2016. my friends who were the
most irritated by Trump
and who just were the most befuddled by
Trump
are the ones who have are not from New
York have never lived in New York and
don't don't know a lot of New Yorkers
and the people who kind of laughed at
Trump or Shrugged him off or got a kick
out of him tended to be the New Yorkers
or people who have spent time in New
York okay this is
Donald Trump
is at his core a New Yorker okay and New
Yorkers make jokes and they're Brash and
they use Hyperbole and they speak with
their hands like I am doing right now
and like Donald Trump does and they bust
people's bullions and they they hit
people and they just you know it's just
the way that they are okay and so
this is going to keep up because Donald
Trump seriously wants to be president I
think
Donald Trump rightly understands that
Ron DeSantis is his chief rival in 2024
and so he's going to keep dinging him
he's going to keep dinging him now this
might this might just turn people off
I've been following a lot of the
commentary on this and a lot of people
are saying look I love Trump I voted for
him twice but enough don't hit why are
you going to hit this good Republican
Governor down in Florida who's doing
great stuff come on man it's two years
away chill out but Donald Trump he is
who he is he is a New Yorker he is Brash
he is bold he hits he fights and so that
is that is just going to happen that is
just baked in the presidential race is
on we're not done counting the votes for
2022. but the race is on okay and for
the people who are saying Trump
shouldn't hit DeSantis give me a break
okay Trump is who he is it's a
presidential contest he's going to do it
and and for Donald Trump by the way who
says Ronda Santos shouldn't run against
me I made him he should be gracious okay
give me a break all right that's insane
this is politics we're talking about the
highest office in the land this is the
time that Ron DeSantis probably has to
run if he wants it the way the Cycles
fall all next time he's probably going
to be yesterday's news and in politics
as in comedy timing is everything so
he's going to run I don't think that
he's a he's a bad man for running
against Trump who helped him win his
first race and frankly I don't think
Trump is a bad man for trying to get his
old job back and for running especially
when he's this high up in the polls this
is politics politics is a really tough
brutal business and the guys who do well
in it are really tough guys who can take
a punch I think DeSantis can take a
punch I think Trump can take a punch
they can both throw them as well and
starting most likely next Tuesday with
that announcement at Mar-A-Lago Trump
could surprise us and not announce but
all all the signs are pointing to him
announcing a run that means 2024 is Off
to the Races now on the Democrat side
for 2024 a lot of people saying Biden
can't run he's just so exhausted
he's so confused he can barely form an
English sentence so
you're going to need a new candidate and
who's the candidate that they're
proposing to to fix all of those
problems about Joe Biden
John Federman of course fetterman as a
nominee at some point for president
um I know there's some variables
obviously but he took a few but I just
you know
what he did in the in the super red deep
red parts of Pennsylvania and the way
that he ran ahead of Biden as you were
saying around ahead of trump I mean it
just makes it makes you wonder about his
future
makes you wonder about his future I mean
John Federman his entire political
experience is uh being the mayor of a
town of 1800 people and briefly being a
lieutenant governor and now having just
been elected to the Senate after not
campaigning because he can't speak
because he's very very ill man with
extremely radical ideas
so he should be president right
maybe he should he's probably going to
be in the senate about as long as Obama
was he's got exactly as many political
achievements under his belt as Barack
Obama did so maybe
it's not the craziest idea
from the beginning the health attack on
fetterman was a loser attack and it was
a loser attack one because it seems kind
of ugly you know you don't want to make
fun of people for having a stroke but
two it's a loser attack because no one
really cares because the job of senator
is not what it once was we used to have
active Senators who would cross party
lines and who were very involved in
foreign policy even and who were
involved in lots of oversight and who
would pass a lot of legislation that's
kind of over the the legislature doesn't
really do most of the legislation most
of the actual legislation at this point
is just pumped out by the federal
bureaucracy which is under the executive
branch so the Senators especially as we
move more toward a kind of parliamentary
style system where the parties are very
clearly defined and the individual
senators are just kind of rubber stamps
for party leadership
just doesn't really matter and frankly I
think the same principle is true for the
president I don't know that it matters
all that much
who the president is if the president is
incapacitated as he is right now by the
way people are saying well fetterman
can't be president his brain isn't
working all that well
uh yeah uh tell me more about that
because the the
machine of government just kind of rolls
on as our government throughout the 20th
century became more of a technocracy
then the legislators and even the
president mattered less and less you
think fetterman 2024 is crazy
I don't think you've seen crazy yet I
think things are going to get a whole
lot crazier than we're looking at right
now and that's why in these periods of
craziness and Chaos you're going to want
some pretty solid assets why you got to
check out Birch gold right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 inflation continues
to plague our economy the daily wire
reports that in less than two years
inflation has soared from 1.4 percent to
8.6 percent as of May 2022 the price of
gas was up nearly 49 the price of meat
poultry and fish was up 14.2 percent and
the price of used cars was up 16 the
current administration's irresponsible
spending patterns including Joe Biden's
1.9 trillion dollar rescue plan continue
to exacerbate the problem now is not the
time to have all your money tied up in
the stock market do not let your savings
wither away hedge against inflation with
gold from Birch gold text Knowles Canada
W Las to 98 98.98 Birch gold will send
you a free info kit on protecting your
savings with gold Birch gold is giving
out a free gold bar with any Purchase
made by December 22nd you must submit
your claim by Black Friday with almost
20 years of experience in converting
IRAs and 401ks into precious metals IRAs
Birch gold can help you too don't sit
around while the fed devalues your
hard-earned money text Knowles Canada
Wes to 98 98 98 and learn how you can
convert at least part of your savings
into a precious metals IRA
if you place an order by December 22nd
Birch gold will send you a free gold bar
text Knowles Canada wlas to 98 98 98
speaking of insane choices in elections
we've talked a lot about the Georgia
Senate race the Arizona senate race
the 2024 presidential contest we haven't
talked a ton about the New Hampshire
Miss America contests okay and we
haven't talked in particular about Brian
noyan
Brian noyan who is the first man to win
the Miss greater Dairy 2023
competition
your new Miss greater Dairy
is Brian noyan and you see him in his
dress and all the poor little cute
blonde girls or they have to pretend to
be happy behind him and then he who is a
for those of you who are not watching
right now for those of you who are only
listening this man is
I don't want to be mean to the guy
he
there's a lot of pretty little blonde
girls around him who look like you know
young blonde girls and then there's this
more corpulent guy a little it just
looks more like a man
and he's bigger and he's just bigger
okay and he is up
he wouldn't have gotten my vote for Miss
greater Dairy I'm not on the Electoral
commission for this contest but
it's
absurd
how did he win
even if he were a woman
it would not make sense for for him to
win this beauty contest okay he probably
has many other virtues and talents but
this would not he should not win so why
why they have to do it they have to do
it because
the left we know hates truth and the
left we know hates goodness and the left
also hates that third transcendental
hates Beauty that's why the leftists all
over the world are throwing soup on on
famous beautiful paintings
that's why they attack beautiful
buildings in beautiful architecture and
they try to burn these things to the
ground the left hates Beauty and so the
left has to redefine truth as falsehood
and goodness is evil and Beauty as
grotesquery
and that is what
they're doing
this this is why now when you see
Billboards for clothing I used to be
you'd go in magazines and you'd see on
billboards for clothing companies you'd
have these beautiful models you know
Christy Brinkley right Heidi Klum oh my
God Tyra Banks you know these really
beautiful people
now you don't see those people on the
Billboards and in the magazines you see
you see big
ugly mutilated people who who make
themselves look uglier than they
otherwise would who contort themselves
and try and and that's they call it
positivity it's not positivity it's a an
inversion of Standards to reorder all of
society that's what they're really after
it's part of the exact same attack on
truth and goodness that we see
everywhere they have to do it
and the and the the saddest part of it
the most sort of stalin-esque
totalitarian part of it is those poor
little girls in the background who one
of whom should have won the contest they
have to applaud they and they have to
smile and they have to say oh this is so
great that this big dude won the girls
beauty pageant we ha ha ha just like all
those girls on the swim team at UPenn
have to smile and applaud when that big
dude will Thomas who calls himself Leah
takes all of their trophies they have to
do it because if they do not
affirm this absurd dominant regime they
will be exiled they will be ostracized
they'll be called awful phobic terrible
people so they have to do it too and
you're supposed to do it too and I'm
supposed to do it too
and I don't and then they take some of
my shows off YouTube and you know don't
invite me to the nice fancy parties and
things like that but
it's a it's a total kind of ideology
it's everywhere it's not just Joe Biden
and that fellow Richard Levine the
assistant Health secretary it's not just
them from the official government posts
who are pushing the trans ideology it's
everywhere it's all the way down to the
little teen beauty pageant in this
greater Dairy
2023
the drag stuff
is now a sort of religious right
for public life and you're this is why
you're seeing all the politicians do it
uh Justin Trudeau has just become the
latest prominent politician to go on a
drag race tv show
[Music]
we welcome the prime minister of Canada
Justin Trudeau
this one is about to go down in history
my jaw just dropped
the most shocking thing about this clip
is how ordinary it is now
you you would have thought two years ago
if a major politician goes on to a drag
queen show that's a shocking thing wow
isn't that so crazy
Trudeau's the third guy to do it
first you had Nancy Pelosi she went on
one of the the American drag queen show
and then AOC went on the exact same drag
queen show
and now Justin Trudeau up in America's
Top Hat goes on the Canadian drag queen
show
this is just what happens now this is a
religious right for politicians
in the old days
politicians who wanted to win office in
the dominant powerful culture would go
to churches
they'd go to a church and you'd see them
with their Bible you know maybe they'd
kiss a couple babies there and you know
they would go to the old religious
rituals in in India when someone wants
to become Prime Minister of India they
go to Varanasi and they go into the
Ganges River because it's considered
holy and they'll sometimes go and the
river is full of bacteria and they'll
sometimes go into the river sometimes
they'll even drink out of the river
which is not very good for their
physical health but but they have to do
it so important is that religious ritual
well that's just what we're seeing now
with the left the left's religious
ritual that you have to perform if you
want to be considered holy in their
extraordinarily Unholy religious View
is you need to bend the knee to the the
weird trans stuff the LGBT stuff you
certainly have to show up to a pride
parade
and
I mean I remember seeing this even 10
years ago at in New York they always
have all these sorts of weird crazy LGBT
parades with the pride parade the
Mermaid Parade on Coney Island Chuck
Schumer was showing up you have to do
that now and now it goes even further
you have to show up for transgenderism
it makes me think of a point that my
friend Alan Estrin said to me yesterday
I was on Alan Estrin who runs Prager
University I got on a call with him and
uh Jeremy we're just sort of catching up
and he said hey guys
uh well welcome to the states of America
and I thought wow that is so incisive
yeah that's a great takeaway from the
midterms we live not in the United
States of America we live in the States
of America we live in different
realities with with different cultures
and different uh not just different kind
of practices but but different religious
views with different languages we don't
even speak the same language with a
different conception of marriage the
Bedrock political institution
with completely different conceptions of
life with completely different
exceptions of the nation state we're
just we have very very little in common
and now if you if you want I mean this
is one of the stories of the midterms is
that people had voted with their feet
which is good news that's why that's one
of the reasons why Florida had such a
great night for Republicans but it's
also one of the reasons why Lee zeldin
the Republican candidate wasn't able to
win in New York he got pretty close but
how many conservative New Yorkers had
just left voted with their feet said I
don't want to live like this anymore I
want to go live in a normal place and so
if you want to win elections in the
normal conservative places then you're
going to have to still keep going around
to those churches and potluck dinners
and if you want to win elections in the
radical leftist States then you're going
to need to go on the drag queen TV show
and those are just those are just
different forms of campaign with
different rights because people have
different fundamental views of the world
one of the other results of
the midterm elections is because Biden
lost I mean let's let's not forget
Republicans still seem to have won they
didn't win by as much as we hoped they
would that we would but Republicans
still won unless something gets a little
screwy in the final vote count uh but
because they didn't win with a huge
mandate Joe Biden was just asked by Zeke
Miller
what are you going to change now after
this midterm sir and he says not a thing
you mentioned that Americans are
frustrated and in fact 75 percent of
Voters say the country is heading into
the wrong direction despite the results
of last night what in the next two years
do you intend to do differently uh to
change people's uh opinion of the
direction of the country particularly as
you contemplate a run for president in
2024. nothing because they're just
finding out what we're doing the more
they know about what we're doing the
more support there is
I'm not going to change a thing forget
about after Bill Clinton gets shellacked
in the midterms and he comes out he says
the Arabic government is over I feel
your pain I hear your midterms
forget about that that's over Joe Biden
says I'm not going to change
a damn thing although frankly even had
he gotten completely destroyed in the
midterms I don't think he would have
changed a damn thing at all because I
think the left is much much more willing
to flex their power right now and and
they've shown this time and time again
forget about the polls forget about what
people want
people broadly don't want you transiting
their kids well the White House is going
to push it
people broadly don't want more migration
White House is going to push it
completely open borders white people
want Energy prices to come down White
House doesn't care
White House is going to shut down energy
production the liberal establishment
does not care what are they going to
change they're not going to change a
thing you know if you're looking for a
change in your job the daily wire is
looking for a senior vice president of
marketing analytics data and operations
I'm told that this is a high profile
executive role with paid relocation to
Nashville this innovator will Design
hire and oversee a world-class marketing
data and analytics team that is built
atop the marketing data stack from CRM
platforms to multi-touch attribution
tools to propensity targeting models
what language is that I don't even know
I don't know what any of I barely know
what those syllables mean this leader
will for example study which daily wire
shows and films most interest the
audience
um
don't think we need to hire a new a new
vice president of whatever the hell to
do that I think that answer is pretty
obvious but anyway they want to do it
maybe that could be a good thing for you
if you understand
what a full marketing data and analytics
stack is head on over to dailywire.com
Knowles and click careers for more
information to apply also the daily wire
was seeking a vice president of paid
media the ideal candidate will be a
seasoned leader and media strategist who
can toggle between player and Coach who
thrives in fast-paced highly creative
environments and is excited to evolve
daily wire's media mix while retaining
Roi in more simple words all those ads
that people ignore or like to skip we
need someone to make it so that they
don't want to ignore it or skip them
having prior experience with
entertainment subscription or high
growth consumer businesses would be a
huge plus as well if this sounds like
you go to dailywire.com Knowles and
click on careers for more information
and to apply
today
The Establishment has bought into
transgenderism even though the people
broadly don't like it even though the
Republicans who did very very well in
the midterms and in recent years
have done so running against
transgenderism and thinking of Ron
DeSantis especially in Florida biggest
winner of the night
during the midterms I'm thinking of
Glenn Younkin in Virginia I'm thinking
of an issue that has brought a lot of
people over from the Democrat side to
the Republican side
The Establishment still pushes it
including the supposedly right-wing
media channels
not all of them but the ones
that have most accommodated themselves
to the elite kind of media apparatus
they go along with it you know I'm not
surprised when NBC and ABC and CNN and
all the New York Times Washington Post
I'm not surprised when they buy into the
absolutely absurd idea that a man is a
woman and that a man who dyes his hair a
crazy color and mutilates his body is
you know puts lipstick on you know is is
totally normal and and brave and
stunning and so so brilliant and you
know should be affirmed in that delusion
I'm not surprised by that
but even I with my low expectations was
surprised I shouldn't be anymore but I
was surprised to see this piece from Fox
News
Fox News tweets out yesterday
breaking barriers lay Finke attributed
her Victory to the rise of queer
political power
I said oh lay Finke who's lay thinking I
look at the picture and it's this
you know poor
caricature of a troubled man who has
pink dyed hair in a woman's haircut and
is wearing a kind of turquoise
woman's top and wearing lipstick and
it's just ridiculous the man should be
in an insane asylum not not in any sort
of political office and then I read the
headline and I thought is Fox News kind
of mocking this absurdity it's Fox News
is this a sort of tongue-in-cheek
but Fox used the pronoun
Fox News is referring to a dude who is
very obviously a dude as her
unironically I think I've got the
article here
Minnesota elect's first transgender
State lawmaker
even though even to use the phrase
transgender seriously
is is just to buy the premise of of the
left which is absurd the idea that there
is such a thing as transgenderism there
is not there is no ontological category
of you know trans women or trans men it
doesn't exist
there are men who wrongly Express their
sexual nature
and women who wrongly Express their
sexual nature but there's no such thing
as transgender
as a as an actual category of being
Minnesota voters have elected the
state's first transgender lawmaker into
office
finke's opponent lost received you know
just 18.5 percent of the vote
when Finke is sworn into office in
January she will replace Alice Houseman
who was first elected to office in 1989.
oh my goodness gracious she her she
many stories will be written about
Minnesota's elections she said in a
tweet quoting the victory fund one
undeniable story is the rise of queer
political power yeah that's true we do
have very queer powers in this country
the principalities and powers of this
world have long been a bit queer and
there are now very explicitly queer
including a Fox News I guess
what is that about guys come on you're
come on you're you're supposed to be the
right wing cable channel you know and if
if even the the supposedly right wing
can even center right conservative cable
channel
is embracing the most insanely radical
leftist idea
possibly in American history
you know who needs Democrats with with
right-wingers like this who needs
leftists
absolutely
pathetic
it's misinformation is what it is to
call that man a woman is misinformation
Elon
censor this tweet it's it's
misinformation
you're not allowed to mention that covid
camp probably came from a Chinese
laboratory or that the vaccine isn't all
that effective at stopping infection and
transmission of covid that's that's
horrible misinformation but you can call
this obvious due to chick and that's
that's
it's true information I don't think so I
don't think so speaking of
misinformation
there was a story on Election dayment
meant to get to it it kind of snuck past
a lot of people
this is a minor story but it happened in
Tennessee and it could have had pretty
serious consequences shows you how
subtle the shenanigans can be
someone gave us this tip and sent us
screenshots and daily wire has has
reported on it
that Alexa the Amazon voice app
uh had information about polling places
you know all of social media had been uh
primed to give people information about
where to go to the polls and how to vote
and so Alexa did this too and when you
asked Alexa
Alexa
what are the polling hours in Tennessee
on Election Day here's what Alexa said
there are no polling hours in Tennessee
ballots must be sent by mail before
election day or returned to a designated
ballot Dropbox or in person to the
county elections Department by 8 pm on
Election Day
if you asked in other states it gave you
the polling hours but in Tennessee it
didn't
and it's not even it didn't like Alexa
couldn't look at look it up on Google or
something like that Alexa didn't have
the right information there was a lot
written there there are no polling hours
in Tennessee
ballots must be sent by mail before
election day or returned
in person to but that's not true
I went there were polling hours I voted
so what's that about
was it malice or incompetence I don't
know
maybe it's incompetence I mean this was
one of the disagreements that some of us
were having on Backstage tonight
is we were talking about the Maricopa
County machines and beds Ben said
charitably perhaps listen don't ascribe
to malice that which is equally
explained by incompetence those Maricopa
County machines it's just incompetence
Maybe
it's incompetence Maybe
the the widespread mail-in ballots in
2020 in Pennsylvania maybe that was
incompetence maybe that burst water pipe
and the stopping of the vote count in
2020 in Georgia maybe that was
incompetence maybe the uh suppression of
the hunter Biden laptop story in 20
maybe that was incompetence maybe Alexa
telling Tennessee voters that there are
no polling hours on on Election Day when
we know that Republicans are more likely
to vote on Election Day and we know
Democrats are more likely to vote before
election day and after they have died we
know that that's that's true too maybe
it's all incompetence but man that's a
sh that's sure a lot of coincidences
isn't it it's just funny how the
incompetence always redounds to the
benefit of Democrats and to the
disadvantage of Republicans
maybe some of it is incompetence and not
malice but it's just the whole system of
it
I think it would be hard to say that
that that whole system of
mistakes and mishaps and that that's all
just incompetence once can be a fluke
twice can be a coincidence three times
seems a little bit more strategic and
systematic
now speaking of issues on Election Day
one issue that as the polls got things
wrong for republicans in those last two
weeks one issue that may have played a
role more than a lot of conservatives
thought
was abortion and in a very specific way
we've known for years now that abortion
does not rank for most people at the
very tippy top of their list of of
issues
when when people are considering issues
the economy crime immigration those
sorts of things tend to rank much much
higher
but there was something this year that
motivated people I think to vote more
specifically on abortion and that's what
might have skewed the polls and that is
that
abortion came up on a lot of ballots in
referendum so it's not just that people
were voting for a pro-life politician or
pro-abortion politician they were voting
specifically on
abortion issues so when abortion is
literally on the ballot
perhaps that motivated more pro-abortion
Fanatics to get to the polls and when
they did that they obviously voted for
Democrats so it's it's sort of one
degree removed from a the normal way
that you would think about voting that
might have explained things as well now
I always think
look especially if Republicans win the
house and and win the Senate then you
say you know okay whatever yeah we
didn't get 56 seats okay fine we got 51
seats or 52 seats whatever
but even if not even if it had cost
Republicans the Senate
to overrule Roe v Wade
totally worth it
of course totally worth it you I just
knew the Supreme Court shouldn't have if
they had just waited and not gone and
overruled Roe v Wade oh well if they
hadn't done that hundreds of thousands
more babies a year would be murdered and
it's true maybe some more
psychopath politicians would have held
some seats in Congress or something but
I don't care I'll rather take the win
the reason that we want to win elections
is to get good stuff done for the
country and and stop the bad stuff
happening in the country right
and I can think of few issues where good
and bad are more
starkly defined than on abortion so
totally worth it but it's worth pointing
out California pro-abortion prop uh was
on the ballot and 65 percent of
Californians voted for it
uh you saw the same thing in Vermont in
Montana Kentucky
well you saw it all over the place
Michigan
did that push you know if the abortion
prop is on on the ballot in Michigan and
it passes passed pretty clearly 56.4 to
43.6 is that what gives Gretchen Whitmer
that extra boost to get over Tudor Dixon
who is a good candidate maybe it is and
maybe that's just the cost first of all
though you can't just say well it's
Trump's fault he picked bad candidates
in a way it is Trump's fault because he
got the conservative judges on the court
who then overruled Roe v Wade so it is
but that's something that I think he
would want to take responsibility for
and you can't just say well it's the
fault of election fraud or well it's the
fault of this that Earth
well it's the fault of even a bad Senate
map
no okay if if it is the case that
abortion actually did play a role in
some of these tighter races okay it's
too bad that the Republican lost but
lost for good purpose because we got a
major major win and we just shouldn't be
so doer and so absolutely depressed okay
conservatives are making big gains
conservatives are taking back some
political power conservatives are
getting more of a specific vision and
it's going to be messy and there's going
to be fighting and there's going to it's
going to be tough and we're going to get
some setbacks
overall though
the conservatives are doing more right
now than they have in my entire lifetime
that's very very exciting now we got to
win those races we've got a very
important conservative lawyer coming on
to help us discuss that that would of
course be
Jenna Ellis the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign